[Musique]
oui j'ai un avis bonsoir vous avez la
semaine dernière donc que dis je la
semaine dernière lors de notre dernière
émission fait la connaissance de robert
courtine
je vous rassure à nouveau raymond a
libéré là il va vous donner une recette
mais robert cantina à nouveau
aujourd'hui quelque chose à nous dire
il n'est plus question alexandre dumas
je crois un espoir au vert non ginette
mathiot
vous êtes les climats et culinaire le
flux du monde entier vos livres sont des
best seller et l'un d'eux je sais
cuisiner à dépasser le tirage d'un
million quel effet cela vous fait d'être
millionnaire aucun aucun sens si vous me
demandiez de loger tous les livres chez
moi parce que ça fait un certain cubage
avancé cet appartement de quatre pièces
diable les dans ce livre alors dans je
sais cuisiner
avez vous choisi une recette que raymond
iv à vannes ou réaliser ce soir oui
j'aimerais beaucoup que raymond à
l'hiver puisse faire aujourd'hui la
recette du pain de macaronis qui est si
je ne me trompe le numéro 1292 dans je
sais cuisiner le pôle macaronis c'est
une
c'est une recette qui me plaît beaucoup
parce qu'elle est d'origine le familial
et bien relevé remo vous faites de la
musique pour faire un peu le macaroni
c'est comme pour la recette du fait des
liens vont faire pause mais damien
prenez un lierre faut faire un bon pain
de macaronis koné de macao tient alors
macaronis qui va cuire
voyez-vous pendant 15 minutes alors dans
l'eau bien dans le temps de neige pas ma
mère dans l'autre salle alors on va
mettre une pincée de sel voilà qui est
fait arriver à enlever un tout qui peut
pour éviter que le macaroni nicholas au
fond de la casserole zenini
150 gr parce que vous faites la moitié
de la recette que john viennent pas que
dans sa recette numéro numéro et 1492
copine hop
mais pourquoi diable numérotée
vaux-borset c'est comme dans les
chinoises mais je crois que c'est plus
facile à trouver on cherche à la table
des matières au lieu de chercher une
page et de regarder trois ou quatre sets
sur la même page on tombe juste sur le
même mode l'arrangé pas la mémoire des
chiffres c'est votre côté cartésien
souvent à la fin je fasse une autre
édition pour que catherine langeais de
vies sauvées des recettes à son goût
mais dites moi vous êtes en plus et
peut-être même d'abord un speed fiche
général d'enseignement ménager en quoi
cela consiste
et l'enseignement ménager est une
discipline scolaire qui est mal connu et
ce mode d'enseignement ménager fait que
bien souvent les gens pensent que ce
sont des choses basso il faut faire le
ménage il faut nettoyer les cuivres etc
mais pas du tout je vous assure que nous
arrivons actuellement dans nos écoles
à l'époque de 1966 à faire un
enseignement qui intéresse les jeunes
filles et qui surtout les prépas à leur
rôle de maîtresse de maison
on leur apprend à acheter on leur
apprend à choisir a critiqué lorsque
quelque chose ne correspond pas tout à
fait ce qu'elle en attendent et on leur
apprend aussi à faire la cuisine à ben
j'espère qu est ce qu on leur apprend à
mettre des tabliers quand elles font la
cuisine tu dis ça c'est pour catherine
langeais bien entendu qui n'a pas bien
entendu je suis à l'école à l'école on
leur donne de bonnes habitudes
mais je voudrais vous dire aussi que
l'enseignement ménager n'est pas un
enseignement particulièrement féminin et
que je verrais très volontiers des
garçons faire de la cuisine nous avons
d'ailleurs des écoles pilotes
là je voulais venir vous êtes encore de
ces femmes qui estimait que quand
l'homme à la cuisine pour hobby il
s'allie partout il dépasse de la
marchandise il fait beaucoup de
vaisselle et il leur fait beaucoup de
vaisselle sale oui je suis un petit peu
c'était pas marqué mais c'est peut-être
pour ça que grimaud l'hiver d'ailleurs a
écrit cuisine pour homme seul sur les
souris j'ai pu pour les doigts oui
c'était site est un lieu d'accueil s'est
retiré à 2 125 exemplaires dont la cvo
faire actifs opposition avec la millions
de madame et mademoiselle mathiot ah non
c'est pas vrai d'ailleurs il est
d'ailleurs utilisé mais c'est un livre
qui était fait pour les gens qui étaient
arrêtés parce que paris départ par des
questions de deux techniques qui vous
qui voulez des personnes de type ce
stade alors c'était un petit peu
l'explication de la technique et puis un
violent aux amateurs et chanel on
n'apprenait pas laver la vaisselle à
laver la vaisselle à messi mage et sens
pratique vraiment voudrait lui jeter des
casseroles quand elles sont sales le
problème c'est ça il faut les jeter
réclame à corps on est cuit à je ne
crois pas non je ne crois pas non il ya
encore quelques minutes
et bien comme étant si vous voulez bien
me décide à l'instant les yeux rougis
pleurer un moule le moule dans lequel on
va le faire tuer tout à l'heure je me
verrais très très grave
il faut il faut qu'il soit très bien
beurré et puis ensuite je vais préparer
les ingrédients mais je vous laisse la
parole proverbe imaginé ce bateau
je pense que vous avez appris la cuisine
avant d'être nuit j'ai appelé à gérer
mais je dois dire que je ne sais pas du
tout du tout au début décidé à devenir
une spécialiste de la cuisine
mais à l'époque où j'ai fait mes études
il n'y avait pas d'orientation
professionnelle etc la directrice du
lycée fénelon qui m'a conseillé en
tenant compte de mes aptitudes de
préparer l'enseignement ménager qui
était une carrière tout couvert très bon
la directrice était d'ailleurs bien
aspirer une longeur était au lycée
fénelon ça ne m'étonnerais points à
alors le sommes tout à fait camarades et
alors il se trouve que je suis je suis
allé dans une école où j'ai appris la
cuisine j'étais très désorienté ce que
je m'attendais pas du tout à me trouver
devant un grand fourneau noir avec une
ou un professeur de cuisine qui nous
disait tout simplement lorsque la viande
est cuite vous la retirez vous la mettez
dans un plat toujours votre esprit
cartésien toujours mon esprit car et je
crois que cette fois ci le lac à rosny
et puis bon et bien l'or puisque vous y
tenez absolument qui alors la laverie où
je suis ravi de la présence de monsieur
courtine cette émission mais alors que
ce soit lui qui cuisent le macaroni
alors que c'est moi qui devrais le faire
mais l'otan semble s'écrire
ça me dépasse et qu'est ce que vous
voulez puisqu'il faut il faut mettre un
ballon comme il en fait vous ne m'aimez
lloris mal madame mademoiselle mathieu
n'a plus rien à faire dans cette
émission monsieur comptines a décidé que
le macaroni et puis à l'aube il et je
suis pressé alors voilà je vais les
bouchers vous êtes accord aussi vous
impliquez-vous presse modèle moitié
voudriez vous je vous prie très inquiète
parce que comme c'est une demie recettes
si par hasard elle est ratée je me
demande si ce sera la faute de robert
comptines ou de remo à l'hiver ou doux
amer à cause de toute façon nos
téléspectatrices sauront voir quand leur
macaron audition puis s'en sont occupés
de raymond l'hiver diderot des recours
qui suffit il suffira en l'occurrence de
voir une montre ça ne me paraît pas très
compliqué car ce sera la vôtre de tout
fait cela alors un petit peu de beurre
dans le macaroni pour éviter qu'ils ne
collent
n'est ce pas là uniquement pour cela
et puis à partir de maintenant je vais
réaliser la recette entièrement se fasse
que je vous fais avoir d'abord que il y
à un bain de macaronique est en train de
fuir car à lui fait ses quinze minutes
qui ont suffi à cuire
la première partie
faire la première partie de la cuisine
du matériau ne suffisent pas il faut une
heure et demie la cuisson total alors là
il y a dans cette cocotte un bain marie
dans ce bain marie ou ya de l'eau et
puis il y à hambourg dans ce cas marie
qu'il y à le pen macaronis qui est en
fin de cuisson
il sera prêt tout à fait au moment pour
l'émission elle-même sera terminé alors
nous y reviendrons tout à l'heure nous
remplacerons la moule par l'autre
d'ailleurs
ce sera je crois très amusant et puis
alors là je vais vérifier bobigny alors
une heure et demie au total
alors maintenant j'ai ici les
ingrédients nécessaires d'abord gérer
les champignons je l'entendais et la
moitié puisque il faut non pas ce n'est
ceux d'il y à déjà quand on dit d'un
bain etc l'état car en fait ici la honte
ou peur à moitié mais dans la recette la
moitié des champignons vont aller dans
le pen macaronis l'autre moitié pas
servir à faire la sauce alors tout à
l'heure immédiatement prendre la moitié
nous allons prendre le fromage de
gruyère râpé
nous avons d'ailleurs moitié ainsi il
est où tout est à moitié
je fais remarquer que je crois que
ginette mathiot mélange lait fromage
laguiole parmesan avec le douillet c'est
une chose que je trouve moi excellent en
tout cas je fais je fais toujours ce
fait toujours je crois qu'elle le fait
aussi dominé le gruyère et le parmesan
en bout en vend plus petites quantités
enfin ça c'est une question de vous
aussi il ne faut pas oublier alors il ya
du jambon un petit oiseau sur l'assiette
mais les oiseaux les non il n'est pas
combien de personnes
moi je pense que la moitié de cette
recette convient parfaitement à 4 donc
la recette totale et pour lui oui 8 à 10
je crois que dans le livre est
d'ailleurs c'est stipulé alors on est où
on va chez le jambon
on va les mains c'est exactement d'une
jambe pour la recette
sial il en faut 150 g donc donc d'annaba
75 non là c'est la moitié 4 janvier on
avait là aussi j'ai 300 à bord alors
allongé patent 15 gr si la recette celle
que nathan 75 alors il si les
champignons bien entendu n'est pas
supérieur de maçon tout à l'heure nous
les humains sont seulement alors voyez
vous j'ai d'abord remercier les le
jambon jeu les hacher grossièrement et
là également et vous je vais tâcher
aussi roman pour 8 personnes 250 g de
champignons sont nécessaires voilà et si
j'en ai suffisamment à l'horizon très
beau très blanc thème les très jolies
jambes bien des secrets grâce à des
cessions bon alors maintenant il me faut
des jaunes d'oeuf et des blenders
combien faut-il de gland 4 et de genres
suggère combien il coûte et parce que
alors le jambon ce que voilà les
champignons que voilà alors les blancs
de logique qu'ils vous avez un nombre
doivent déterminer
6 alors la danse est 6e nous allons
trois roues pour vous puisque moi j'ai
la recette 3 3e on voit là et nous
allons nous allons directement les
blancs ici nous allons le faire à la
machine pendant que les frondeurs chose
à jouer pour clarifier les deux fois ci
existe des machines à clarifier le nôtre
pas existe-t-il
il existe des petits appartiennent la
jaune et le blanc coule se faire des
petits trouver une adresse igadget dans
les maîtresses de maison se serre mais
quelquefois non alors je crois que ce
sont des gadgets que les maîtresses de
maison hachette
mais quand elle se sert jamais ses
doigts de ses traites à payer ailleurs
qu'aucun réseau poulaga vous surprendre
c'est parce qu'on cantonale a besoin le
trouve pas on sait pas où ils sont on
sait qu'ils existent mais non là vous
parlez encore des femmes et maîtresses
de maison non ordonnés qui n'ont pas
suivi les conseils 22 mathew alors voyez
vous je vais aller commander ici et
blanc des munitions pendant que les plus
bluffants nous font remonter je vais
mélanger tout cela ensemble a besoin je
suis fonctionnaire pareil dans mon dos
d'un autre côté la foule se met une
histoire d'ailleurs qui ressemble
j'ai lu cette histoire de séjour était
une femme est très désordonnée alors son
mari lui dit tu devrais jouer au tiercé
on lui dit pourquoi pas ce que tu le
touches est dans le désordre vous et
laissez vos légumes de la bonne volonté
ambiance art et l'isi alors là croyez
vous je suis en train de mélanger c'est
assez compliqué ce petit mélange car il
s'agit de bien incorporer les jaunes
avaient lancé
et puis là ne pas oublier de fromage du
joaillier a fait danser oublier ça alors
je voulais vous m'aidiez à 4 et qu'est
ce qu'il ya comme assaisonnement ajouté
parce que le mariage est salée alors
voilà poivre et muscade
c'est ça que je voulais savoir à
l'envoyer comme un récipient gheniff a
tellement ça sur un os
il faut que l'on voit aspects qui font
un immense chaudron je vais travailler
l'enfant personne ne sera si si s'il se
passe quelque chose s'il ne se passe
rien vers 20h20
sans nom mais c'est parce que cette
médaille est passé alors j'ai mis la
musique à ses calculs et à la pétition
que le temps se mélanger je savais de
poivre et de muscade et arrêter vraiment
arrêter vous c'est fini n'en parlons
plus voilà les blancs étaient montés
alors je voudrais ici ce petit appareil
pourtant
[Musique]
là alors vous avez monter les blancs
oui les blancs en neige
je m'en vais les mettre tout de suite là
dedans j'ai passé et ginette mathiot que
dans votre recette
vous auriez pu vous l'avez dit qu'il
nous alors je vais vouloir modifier pas
si colas le fait de monter le clan des
nanas n'ajoutez pas grand chose j'aurais
par tuer tout bon le mouvement des jeux
en omelette un petit peu mou ce seuil en
outre nous aurait mis j'aurai tout me
jean emile et les gens et dublin dans le
parterre je pense que ce soit monsieur
comme une longue lettre la mère poulard
je vous demande de respecter la recette
nous faisait mathieu mais c'est ce que
je fais à catherine c'est ce que je sais
je fais je voudrais bien je voudrais lui
demander de penser chance la salle y
penser même je crois que ce serait un
service arabe à certaines personnes qui
n'ont pas qu'ils n'ont pas l'abatteur
automatique on voir sur ma terre
automatique on bat très bien les blancs
à la main bon et bien voilà non mélangés
terminé que les personnes qui n'ont pas
nova de batteur automatiques peuvent
très bien des faits mélanger et bien
l'acheteur
et oui ma face à leur évite un certain
travail et comme c'est un plat vraiment
de caractère familial photo essayé de
simplifier la tâche vous suis
reconnaissant
parce que j'ai bien fait attention de ne
pas vous mettre du beurre aux portes ou
là sur ce merveilleux c'est tout ce
mélange aux maîtresses devenus tous les
matins bon et bien catherine voyez vous
pas de mollesse
nous allons mettre le macaroni dans le
mourre aucun accord ni le maccabi
plus marquants oui oui c'est vrai que ça
faisait quand vous dites votre nom mais
moi je suis outré là je suis les
recettes de mademoiselle mature elle dit
mettez votre pelle macaronis dans votre
cour avec votre main droite elle dit ces
choses et bien la raison c'est comme ça
qu'il faut faire
bon alors regardez regardez bien gardé
je vais prendre cela on peut avoir bien
racler le fond parce que c'est ce
qu'elle meilleures et où le champignon
le land of de safetic siens je vais
mettre à la place du moule qui est en
train qui a fini de cuir je vais mettre
celui-ci
alors je vous laisse y ait assisté à
cette opération parce que je risque de
me voulait et je sais que c'est que quoi
oui si je me brûle vous rirez un tout
petit peu vous dirai à raymond royer
comme moi n'ont aucun système et comment
je m'appelais en général coiffé le fan
macaronis laissera un autre se fait
directement mon pass d'un caveau ni donc
20 ma vie alors remarquer que
mademoiselle mathieu a dit mon bain de
maccarone enfants la vie et de la
famille mais on va dire que c'est comme
ça que forment les gens et bien
maintenant catherine jeu m'avait préparé
la source interrogée lundi matin
attendez une seconde pour ça il me faut
des champignons et de la crème pendant
je vais faire la sauce vous allez dire
le petit mot que vous avez envie de nous
dire à tous et de venir à vous en
particulier
est-ce que vous avez des souvenirs de
harry magie de la cuisine y est
maintenant
1080 que monsieur curtis est très vieux
os parler d'une histoire qui avait
d'abord de tout brûler fort moi je m'en
souviens très bien
et le jeu harry magie de la cuisine
existe toujours et le concours que nous
avions fait ce n'était pas un concours
c'est un concours en quelque sorte la
suggestion de recettes
ils pourraient être soumis bien un objet
bon je m'amuse moudre aux finances et
d'aubergines des recettes d'aubergines
si on avait des quantités n'est ce pas
monsieur jean figadère j'avais les
messieurs jean clavel à châteaurenard
dans les bouches du rhône
eh bien vous avez gagné art et magie de
la cuisine j'ai de la famille à noter
également madame n entendons pas son nom
nous avons juste entendu son nom
madame fernande durant pour des recettes
de cet effort mais ça c'est parce que
moi j'aime laisser wifi savez vous où
elle habite à tartas et c'est pas vous
qui dans l'élan voilà à tartas dans les
landes madame fernande durant voile à un
ris magie de la cuisine un petit jus
pour vos enfants et pour tout le monde
cela dit nous allons retrouver à nouveau
remarquer que quand on est un vrai
l'ambiance a fait le pas durant
s'appelle la paix on s'appelle par mail
et peut-être pas là duboscq mais en
attendant nous allons retrouver robert
courtine et ginette mathiot et bien
ginette mathiot
parlez nous un peu de vos expériences
culinaires qu'est ce que vous avez
appris la vie
oui bien sûr et je vous assure que j'ai
parfois des appréhensions
nous avions des pleurs que nous devions
réaliser pour des épreuves
des concours et une de mes plus grandes
inquiétudes chez les croqueurs de pommes
de terre vous dire le nombre de fois que
j'ai réalisé les croqueurs de pommes de
terre parfois 5 6 fois par semaine je
faisais mes révisions si vous voulez
comme un bon étudiant et ses révisions
pour passer les compositions et je vis
j'ai ma famille régulièrement à manger
des désastres de croquettes de pommes de
terre
et si vous vous imaginez ça va donner
aux parents l envie d'envoyer leurs
filles alliance est ménagé pour moi j'ai
des crampes de pommes de terre matin et
soir
non mais rassurez-vous a toujours
déployé lui moi j'ai toujours hâte et
les lentilles farsi et je suis très
motivé a raté quelque chose a eu
beaucoup de mal avec les quenelles
j'avais inventé afin de prétendre à ce
moment-là rice qui les ai inventées
beaucoup plus tard en fait décoller le
de lamproie sinon comme la lamproie
passe rarement dans la garonne est le
monde opaque et après ça s'est fini avec
la police 7 ou 8 ans on va mourir parce
qu'ils attendent l'année prochaine des
navires a commencé à me trompe et annick
mademoiselle martiaux et les cicatrices
non communautaires tous les jours moi
j'ai essayé de les vendre aussi en plus
j'essayais de faire croire aux clients
que c'était comme ça qu'il fallait que
ce soit alors j'étais beaucoup plus
compliqué lundi c'était la famille enfin
vous voyez quelques on peut rater
quelque chose fait à la fin mais il y
avait des souvenirs un peu désespérée
mais d'ailleurs on se demande au fond
pourquoi on s'acharne
un raté quelque chose alors ils ont
elles fait un peu la veille sur nous les
croqueurs de pommes de terre su protéger
mon bon tu l as we en tant que supporter
à face et tous nos étudiants la compote
de pommes de terre
enfin c'est bon à côté du kif tv à côté
de la sauce quand on a préparé avec des
ris de veau et puis les revenus ont
flambé enfin tout ça mais au fait de
pommes de terre
accessoirement à côté non pas cet avis
beaucoup mieux que les cannes l endroit
de toute façon la voilà ça j'ai obtenu
les positions je vais presser
actuellement ce qui est sûr en tout cas
c'est que je n'ai pas pu puisque vous
nous avez dit renée fleming un honneur
mais voyez vous c'est en cuisson alors
maintenant les terminer je vais terminer
la sauce voyez vous les jeux reprend le
terme de ginette mathiot ces champignons
on bouillie dans lui je repense à terme
car il n'est pas en termes habituels de
la cuisine et je voudrais le préciser ça
veut bien dire ce que ça veut dire
il s'agit pas de les faire sauter de les
faire rissoler mais de les faire cuire
en quelque sorte à l'étouffée dans le
beurre c'est ce qui a été le cas ici
alors on ajoute 150 g de graines ne pas
sauter la moitié seulement pour l'heure
l'occurrence et ça fait soixante quinze
n'est ce pas c'est bien ça
regardez six ans ses 175 125 je me suis
trompé un petit peu mais ce n'est pas
énorme
et voilà la sauce voyez-vous la sauce
qui va accompagner le pain de macaronis
alors ce père m'a confié avoir laissé
fuir la sauce il va falloir de la season
aussi car là il n'y a aucun
assaisonnements alors je pense que le
même assaisonnement que celui qu'a
convenu pour peindre mac orly doit
également convenir à sept cents soit un
peu de sel du poivre de la muscade alors
liée au dés que il va y avoir une
ébullition violence cette sauce va
épaissir sur elle-même et elle va être
tout à fait tout à fait et maintenant
vous allez devoir subir l'examen dans
l'est
vos juges savent pas prendre ce que ça
va rester là c'est pourquoi quatre alors
les leaders et les regards mais de ceux
ci à petit feu je m'en vais reprendre ce
moule pour le démouler dans un bar que
voilà c'est pas trop j le remarquer je
t'en donne pas des précautions
supplémentaires mais ce n'est pas
fragile mais il faut bien sûr même très
chaud alors alors voilà le pain de
macaronis on va le mettre bien ça va
donner une inclinaison normale sur ce
point macaronis nous allons ajouter la
sauce limina la sas à leurs gros c'est
d'une simplicité très grande visite est
ce la moitié des champignons qui on est
et émincer bouillie dans le beurre dans
lesquels on ajouter la crème de lait on
a ajouté l'assaisonnement et voilà et
c'est terminé
alors voyez vous ici voilà le bain de
macaronis recettes 8297 du collectif
voilà quatre ans comme les nouveaux
numéros testé pas mal à paris comment je
peux porter porté comme une famille de
cuillé s'ils veulent vraiment amazon au
métro ils sont équipés et croyez moi oh
là là on n'a pas répété pour rien vous
savez vous permettez je pose là là je
vais me retirer pour laisser le juge
entre vous quelques instants bons trades
au rappel nos jeux
allez jury de dégustation oui ou les
pâtes sont généralement toujours trop
cuite zone cervelle ici je pense
qu'elles ne sont pas trop menacés fait
remarquer que j'avais donné le oui merci
cette sauce mais c'est clairement donc
avait bien sûr quand on fait des livres
de cuisine il faut être gourmand à la
merci beaucoup et nous allons mettre une
note blanche est où elle élève il évalue
les bonsaïs à un préjudice favorable en
fou que ça fait un peu tout frais tient
bon mais tu es je mettrais quand même
cédé à lui 6 9 et demi c'est délicieux
combien généreux 19e nuit 20 ans et
méchas que si je le faisais alors voilà
des bisses va c'est simplement des
comptes et la jugeant extrêmement
particulier doucement parce qu'à bercy
oui on est bien d'accord mais bravo
robert koch il n'avait oublié j'ai
l'impression ce que vous leur avez donné
à manger là c'est pas celle que vous
avez fait pendant l'émission puisqu'il
fallait une heure à l'elysée malgré ce
qu'a dit raymond les macaronis doivent
être cuits et bien c'est les macaronis
pour être bon dans vote il est en cours
dans votre les troubles ont fait une
chanson 2009 jean même s'il a dit ça nos
téléspectateurs qui sont là
l'art à votre gauche ont demandé s'il
avait voulu oublier
non non vous leur dites bonsoir bon
appétit bonsoir bonne impression c'est
le temps de faire si c'est pour le
réveillant oui et nous remercions
ginette mathiot pour sa recette numéro x
et 1492 à l'envoyeur
mais pas et merci revers coupé
[Musique]